one of the things Hamas did was offer
social services so some people have a
relationship with Hamas that at one
point was in some ways positive even if
the things they're doing now are
negative it's a very complicated
relationship some of them I'm sure are
deeply resentful and also feel tied to
it it's like a it's like a battered
battered husband battered wife
relationship probably someone over there
is is essentially held hostage and there
are ultimately always going to be
Palestinians who feel as though Israel
is in the wrong for being there at all
absolutely even if they're not
sympathetic to us they don't want to
dispute the they feel entitled to yeah
one of the first things I saw after the
initial air strike uh after Israel's
first initial air strike was that it was
the picture oddly enough of uh it says
this is what it looks like after Israel
um dropped bombs on Gaza and he says
just kidding this is Minneapolis after
the George Floyd riots in 2020 so that
actually ties those together even more
yeah because it looked almost the same
cuz Minneapolis was uh destroyed